[Music]
[Applause]
Washington head coach kayn dor is
joining us now second year is the huskys
head coach they're undefeated they are
ranked fifth in the nation and they got
a visit to USC coming up this weekend
coach how's
morale we're good yeah it's another game
week and uh you know uh the the season
you know it's slow kind of in the
beginning and then all a sudden you get
past the Midway point and it just flies
by but uh we're enjoying the journey and
excited about a big game this weekend
when did you find out how good your team
was well I think I think we knew um
going into the season with a lot of
returners um from a season a year ago um
11- two and in in a bowl game uh victory
in the alma Bowl against Texas um I
think with a lot of those guys coming
back we had a an idea that it would be a
good year um and you know you just got
to still you know catch some breaks and
uh stay healthy along the way and that's
what we're trying to do here as we uh
grind out the last month of the Season
what's your uh Michael penck Jr moment
where you'll tell your kids
about well hopefully it's uh still to
come but uh um man there's just so many
um because there's the part about him as
a person and just who he is and um the
amazing things he does for our community
and how big of a a role model he is um I
mean emails and phone calls and texts
upon texts of just what he's doing
outside of the the buildings the the
building in the walls here um but I
think um you know did you know what you
had with Michael penx so you get there
and he transfers yeah I I mean he was be
really talented when I was with him in
2019 in Indiana you could tell he was
special um the arm strength and the
accuracy um just kind of the Instinct
instincts and um just you know could put
it wherever he wanted to whenever he did
uh want to and uh he stood in the pocket
and would take the hits if he knew he
had a throw that could be made um and
then you know you see that happening now
as the season goes along and uh probably
the big moment would have been um the
the throw the touchdown pass in the last
final minutes against Oregon here just a
few weeks ago but uh man the guy's a
become a dynamic leader um just amazing
person overall what does he do better
than Caleb
Williams uh I don't know if want to get
into that I think you know they have
different styles um different offenses
um you know we uh we love the way
Michael runs our offense but we
certainly know this weekend that uh
we're going to have our hands full
against a very good quarterback you know
he's not the reigning Heisman for
nothing um just the ability to run and
pass uh create you know eyes down field
um a lot of respect for what Caleb
Williams is doing uh there at USC how do
you simulate that in
practice we have we do have a couple uh
guys that can move around around and and
and create um and so we just tell him uh
you're going to be wore out by the end
of the week and uh he's doing a good job
U will Haskell is doing a good job
trying to trying to make those things
happen for us what do you see with USC's
defense that everybody seems to be
taking advantage of well you know what
you're probably not going to give me
your secrets here but this is a bad
defense here how do you take advantage
of what has been a very bad defense I I
think it's it's it's really still I mean
you can look at the last couple week
where we uh haven't finished drives and
uh we just got to score touchdowns in
the Red Zone it's focusing on us but
doing what we do from from our our
motions and shifts and uh you know just
trying to cause some hesitation and uh
you know they can run um they can fly
around they're explosive and so um you
know I think it's just more a matter of
doing what we try to do against every
other team it's uh just you know making
them communicate and making them have to
make the plays and and trusting that our
athletes uh are are uh you know uh have
the talent and ability which they do uh
to go out there and get it done do your
players know about your college
career no we don't we don't talk much
about that so uh we're we're in their
time right now I think you should get
some highlight are there highlights of
you I know you you were a really good
receiver in college I think you should
just break that out like game film where
they think they're going to be watching
game film and then you just show them
your highlight re coach I got a feel
there be a lot of laughs a lot of lot of
Jabs coming my way so we're just better
keeping that on the down low I think so
but uh no these guys are these guys are
fun seeing these guys do what they do uh
we we do have a great time together I'm
sure they've poked around a little bit
here and there trying to figure out uh
who myself and many of the staff are how
many stops along the way have you had to
get to where you are at Washington I
don't know the number but um it's got to
be 6 S8 you know um couple stops at at
Fresno uh State you know two stops just
at one place one as a offense
coordinator one as a head coach but uh
wouldn't trade my journey for anything
um I think having the ability to be an
assistant with so many good coaches head
coaches um build great relationships
with uh you know peers that were sitting
in the same offensive staff room and and
as an assistant with myself who who many
are on my staff right now um just the
the grind of it all uh continuing to
learn I would trade it for anything good
luck this weekend coach we appreciate
your time yeah thanks for having me on
it's uh kayin dor he was a good receiver
in uh you know small College also a
great coach in small College as well the
Huskies are ranked fifth in the nation
they're at USC they host Utah at Oregon
State and then they host Washington
state run the table and you're in the
National Title picture there